this is a different panel from the one I
shared this morning uh looking at the
science of aging and where that is
taking us in recent years there has been
I mean aging something we've worked on
for decades the science Community has
but in recent years a really explosion
in not just aging science but the number
of scientists working on Aging the
number of new institutes opening up to
do it but also new biotechnology
companies trying to develop drugs to
treat aging and I want to explore what's
going on in aging science why that's
happening and where it could be taking
us I think that's possibly the most
interesting of all these questions at
the moment we've got a fantastic couple
of guests here to help us explore that
uh Professor Lynn Cox is sitting right
next to me here a bio let me guess right
now a biogerontologist uh at the
University of Oxford and uh Lynn is
principal investigator of the lab of
aging and cell senescence at the
department of biochemistry at Oxford
we'll come on to what senescence is in a
minute so don't worry if you don't know
what that is and also Stephen cave who's
director of the lever Hume center for
the future of intelligence and the
senior research Associates
um on in the faculty of philosophy at
the University of Cambridge thank you
very much for joining us Steven's
researching the context of this at least
focuses on the ethics of life extension
and he's also offered two excellent but
well one excellent book on aging and
another one that's yet just about to
come out as well so
um we'll follow that let's just Dive In
when what is the difference between
getting older and aging because I think
at the heart of this we're saying and
Steve horvatha was saying there is a
difference we don't all age in the same
way is that what's really at the heart
of all this
yeah um so my view is that there are two
types of Aging there's chronological
aging which is how many birthdays you've
had and biological aging which is how
fast things start to go wrong
um with the passage of time and
biological aging is different for every
single one of us and it depends on what
we call the exposome so your lifetime
exposures right from when you are in
utero all through your life so where you
live what you eat how much exercise you
have how much stress and and that can be
stresses from communities so people who
live in areas of violent crime have more
stress people who are exposed to high
fat diets in childhood age faster
they're all these sorts of things that
make us age faster things that we can
actually modify but also things we can't
so everyone's got different genes they
inherit a mix of their genes from their
mothers and their fathers and that
actually changes how we age and then you
heard Steve Horvath talking there and
Steve works on little switches on the
genes that determine what gets switched
on and what gets Switched Off and those
switches can be changed by our
environment by everything that we're
exposed to so aging is different for
everybody no one should ever be blamed
for getting sick when they get old
because it's not your fault even though
there's all these so-called lifestyle
factors but it is a combination of
everything that you have lived through
in your lives that affects your
biological age
as opposed to how many birthday cards
you've had how many times you've been
around the Sun oh come on to talk about
what some of those the drivers of that
are but Stephen I was thinking we do all
experience Aging in very different ways
I think we're all very aware of that we
talk about a good a good old age some
people we know live till 106 years old
smoking 20 cigarettes a day and others
live very very healthy lives but die
very young from chronic illnesses our
perception of Aging as humans is that
embedded and important in this
discussion well our perception of Aging
has changed very little over the last
few thousand years I mean if you go back
to the Bible then you hear people living
three school years and ten or or you
know if they're particularly strong four
score years so 70 or 80 in Hindu
Traditions you see the same
um you know in Shakespeare who talks
about the seven stages of life so our
basic conception of what a life looks
like has changed very little even though
life extension has really uh uh doubled
almost in the last 150 years or so but
that of course was largely through
solving the problems around infinite
mortality so the vision of what a good
human life looks like has changed very
little but now and only in the last few
decades have we started to ensure that
older people can also live much more
healthily you know if you look back to
accounts of older people in Shakespeare
for example they're described as a
senile as losing their senses as losing
their powers but now it's possible
through the ways in which we understand
a healthy lifestyle and also medical
interventions of course for older people
to live much better than they ever have
before
so
is there a biological limit to how old
we can get and if so what is it that's
underlying that and therefore what are
the targets that aging scientists are
interested in looking at okay
okay you mentioned the people who live
to 106 and are smoking and drinking and
doing all the wrong things
um
so a colleague near barzilla in America
has identified a group of people who
live their super centenarians they live
well over 100 sometimes 100 and 10 115
in good health they still die
um they go to bed they don't wake up so
we know that healthy long life is
possible but we know that nobody has
ever made it past 122 and a half and
that was John calmon a French lady who
quite remarkably uh is is the longest
documented lived human
but we think that there is a limit and
with these super centenarians what
seemed to happen is their bodies just
simply ran out of steam so
um our bodies keep replenishing
themselves they keep restoring
themselves through things called stem
cells that divide and make new cells and
these super centenarians simply ran out
of stem cells
so of course there's this thought that
if you replace the stem cells you might
carry on going for a little bit longer
I'm not sure whether that really is the
case we accumulate a lot of damage over
our lifetimes as well and simply putting
in a few cells that might repair things
might not be enough I'm not also sure
that that's what we should be doing and
that's another point that we ought to be
coming on to come on to but help me
understand so we we clap out as we get
older but what are some of it but as I
understand it there are several sort of
pillars that scientists look at that are
driving this aging process
is there a sense that they can be
firstly identified and then if we found
them can we actually interfere with them
to to prolong healthy life yeah
absolutely so in 2013
things that are shared across all aging
common things that make us age and
they're called the Hallmarks of aging
and they're they all happen at the
cellular and molecular levels but you
don't have to be a molecular biologist
to understand them so
um things like as we live our lives we
get exposed to things like ultraviolet
light or you go for a medical x-ray that
damages your DNA so accumulation of DNA
damage over your lifetime
makes you get older too much sun gives
us wrinkles Sun can yeah I mean you look
at people's faces when they're very Sun
exposed their skin ages faster
um too many medical x-rays will make you
age faster unfortunately children who've
had bone marrow transplants and full
body irradiation they age much more
quickly so we know that these sorts of
things can drive aging
um things that happen inside ourselves
so we're all breathing oxygen and we
need it and we all eat food and we burn
that food to make energy but those
processes inside our cells can actually
make us get old as well so everything
that we do that keeps Us Alive is also
aging us so oxygen forms a harmful form
of oxygen that runs around our cells and
damages the molecules there as we get
older we can't get rid of those so young
people and young people's cells have
housekeeping processes they take out the
rubbish on a regular basis as you get
older your cells get a bit lazier they
can't take out the garbage so you
accumulate a load of junk in your cells
as you get old
you older cells don't respond to
nutrients in their environment properly
instead of going okay I've got an enough
calories I'm going to stop here and I'm
just going to sort of be a cell that
does what it needs to do they they can't
signal properly they can't understand
the signal of the nutrients coming in to
give the right response at the other
side so they just carry on growing and
grown and growing but they can't divide
and if they can't divide they can't
repair your tissues so we know all sorts
of things like this like the stem cells
just running out of steam so these are
all the Hallmarks of aging and they all
seem to integrate pull together to drive
cells into a process called senescence
and and cell senescence is simply normal
body cells that have accumulated a whole
pile of stresses and changes over time
to a point at which they stop dividing
otherwise they'd be very dangerous so be
cancer cells because they've got loads
of DNA damage and loads of rubbish
accumulated so they don't divide but
they sit there and they don't just sit
there they sit there and do harmful
things so they kick out inflammatory
mediators we saw in the video
information so signals they're sending
signals to the rest of your body so we
call them zombie cells so they're Undead
they should be dead but they're not
um but they're worse than just sitting
around not being dead because they harm
everything else around them so senescent
cells in your body as they accumulate
with age are making you get older I mean
I've got some around my eyes because I
can tell they're eating a whale tissue
structures and that's why you start
getting wrinkles but they also eat away
all the structures around your blood
vessels and make them thinner and well
sometimes more rigid but the actual
structures become less elastic so your
blood pressure changes all these sorts
of things are happening because of your
cells going bad it's really depressing
but
and I wanted to pick up on that point so
we understand this stuff we've been
building our knowledge but what's been
happening the last few years Steve I
mean
certainly over my career I think aging
science is often slightly looked down on
it's a bit of a kind of bit of a
crackpot feel there was some
extraordinary claims made by various
people that we could live for a thousand
years people injecting themselves with
strange Therapies
some quite poorly family things
what's the history of the science of
Aging very briefly and but why is things
why have things sort of moved on now yes
well well the history of a science of
Aging is as old as history I mean the
first recorded a story we have the Epic
of Gilgamesh is about his pursuit of a
cure for aging and and death
and it's a constant throughout history
and you can find in all the great
civilizations in ancient Egypt some of
the best papyruses that have been
preserved are you know things like a
list of medical remedies this is what
you do if you have a cold this is what
you do if you have a broken leg this is
how you stop aging and of course some of
these remedies were more successful than
others and from the very beginning of
Western science we also see the goal of
stopping aging and delaying death or
even curing death
as absolutely at the Forefront so you
know Francis Bacon for example Sir
Francis Bacon is considered one of the
um fathers of modern science of the
empirical method
um wrote a book about life extension
technology and uh one it was about 65
traveling towards London in a carriage
on a cold winter night when it occurred
to him that snow might act in ice might
act as a preservative of um of living
living flesh he got out bought a chicken
from a local Farm shoved it full of snow
and and got back into his Carriage he
unfortunately caught a cold he lived
long enough to see that the snow did in
fact help preserve the chicken but then
he died of pneumonia now
this is ironic but there are interesting
things we can learn from this yes it's
one of the goals of Science and
Technology yes it's full of wild hopes
which aren't you know ever fulfilled and
probably won't be but at the same time
there is real progress you know he
didn't find the cure for aging but of
course you know freezing
cryopreservation really is an essential
part of preserving tissues and and so on
and through to the 20th century we we
saw a lot of different experiments a lot
of interest
um you know less than 100 years ago
people were taking vasectomies having
vasectomies thinking it would cure aging
they were having bits of monkeys
testicles grafted onto themselves bits
of guinea pig ground up and injected and
and so on and these were serious
scientists some of them Nobel Prize
winners and uh and a lot of very famous
people fell for these
um you know much hyped breakthrough
Technologies of of their day but because
they then you know of course they didn't
work there was a placebo effect but then
they didn't work and as you say aging
research did fall into disrepute uh and
through in the latter half of the 20th
century a lot of researchers you know
would would call it by other names and
be very very careful about the claims
that they were making
not though hasn't it it seems to have
come into its own I mean so it's about
Silicon Valley money to a large extent
and it's about the California Dream I
mean you know Aldous Huxley that you
know all through a Brave New World was
satirizing the dream of living forever
among Californians a hundred years ago
so this hasn't come from nowhere you
know it's part of the Californian dream
of you know life's beautiful we can use
technology to solve all of our problems
and and we can live forever in this in
this paradise
um he was satirizing 100 years ago but
then uh of course what we've seen with
the rise of big Tech is is huge amounts
of money and people getting rich and
these are people who are used to getting
what they want they're incredibly
powerful and like powerful people
throughout history they reach middle age
and think oh my God you know I've got
all this money what users said if I'm
dead in 20 years and so they're now
throwing their money at serious
anti-aging research and of course and
you know and they're they're buying the
time of great scientists who are doing
real research and we really do
understand the body much better than we
did 100 years ago so there really is
progress now so what's the what's the
promise then I mean there's a dystopian
view of this which is the Silicon Valley
super wealthy conceal themselves in some
sort of oxygen tent take the stem cells
live for a thousand years while the rest
of the world just carries on shuffling
rapidly towards the grave
um or is there a promise of of medicines
that potentially could really as um as
Christian was saying in that report
there improve health span you give give
most of us healthier lives yeah
yes
um very simple answers so there are some
very very expensive Technologies being
developed some very expensive
Therapeutics fancy antibodies fancy stem
cells costing hundreds of thousands of
pounds but what we also know from
studying these key Hallmarks of Aging is
that a lot of them can be modified by
drugs that we already have that have
already been used in people they're
known to be relatively safe as safe as
drugs can be and they're Dirt Cheap
because they're off patent so you don't
have to pay big Pharma an absolute
Fortune for drugs that will actually do
interesting things so you asked about
the change in the field I would say one
of the absolute key things that happened
2011 a paper came out scientists publish
in esoteric journals and it never really
makes the Sun or the daily mail or
whatever but it's really a key paper
came out that showed that if you remove
senescent cells from old mice they live
longer but they live healthier all all
of their tissues regenerated rejuvenated
they were much healthier for much longer
and that I think flipped the field on
their head up to that point it had been
we can observe things we can see things
go wrong but we can't really do anything
about it and then suddenly there's a
paper going you can change it you can do
something about it and from that point I
think that's where a lot of the the
Silicon Valley Tech got interested
because now it's a technological problem
how do we do this rather than can we do
this and that that has really
transformed the field and the other
thing that's transformed it is all the
new biology everybody here probably
knows that we can now sequence our
genomes the first human genome costs
three billion pounds to sequence now you
can do it for a hundred pounds or so
it's it's phenomenal what we can do in
terms of the tech and biology is
complicated and complex so they're
slightly different things but complexity
means how many different moving Parts
there are essentially and we've got 37
trillion different cells all talking to
each other in different ways that's
quite hard to get your head round but Ai
and Quantum Computing and all this sort
of stuff is now letting us look at
biology in a very different way we call
it big biology and so we can start to
think and in terms of what's Happening
one of our cells is affecting everything
else around the body and if we tweak one
particular process in a Cell what's the
outcome going to be so we know that we
can modify this stuff new technologies
Gene editing Technologies new
observations new yeah new biology I
think it is come of age now so we can do
something I want to do some type of
questions but just really briefly if we
can where are we heading to with this
right is is it that dystopian view or
should we should we be wary of that or
what's your
what what's your what would be your best
preferred option in terms of how we
could use this science to better
Humanity but Stephen first of all give
me your thoughts on that we have a
choice as a society I mean but debate
for 100 thousands of years has been
split between optimists who are like you
know to give me the Elixir give it to me
now I want to live forever
um and those who say no it's not
possible and even if it were possible it
would be terrible you need to be
overpopulation and boredom and
meaningless and so on we need to move
Beyond this sort of utopian versus
dystopian Vision to say to ask ourselves
well okay if there really is going to be
progress we really are going to be able
to live for longer how do we manage that
how do we make sure there's that you
know our education systems are robust
enough that our pension systems are
robust enough that we can live in
harmony with the planet it'll be I mean
if there really are advances in the next
10 or 20 years which there might well be
and we need to take that possibility
seriously then we're going to face
immense challenges as a society and we
can make it work out but only if we take
those issues seriously
fabulous right let's take some questions
from our audience I'm sure there's
there's a gentleman there I might take
two at a time because that's often a
better way to get through a few and
there's a gentle at the back so let's
take your question first sir
yeah just a simple question
um so I've been watching David Sinclair
on YouTube a lot of this he talks a lot
about aging
um and the mice example He also
mentioned is slowing down has science
um actually reversed aging
great has science reversed aging and you
sir yes I'm pointing oh he's got a
microphone already wow this is good
we've got two nights go ahead I've got a
slightly different kind of question
which is actually
um Medical Science has a kind of
prolonged kind of human life but the
thing is it's kind of you know if you're
a person of age now and you go to
hospital it's almost well what is your
quality of life you know to have certain
kind of serious surgeries Etc so is it
like a theoretical limit actually where
say for example if you were born in the
1900s you've probably seen so many
people that passed away technology has
changed Etc so like you know where is
the will to live because you've almost
outlived yourself as well so where does
that fit in I suppose it's that question
yeah
can we reverse it
um that's a slightly tricky question
because we have to be able to measure
aging there is one very very small trial
in America that has looked at a marker
of biological age those little Gene
switches the epigenetics which is on
things and suggests that if you take if
if you're a Silicon Valley middle-aged
man who takes growth hormone and a
couple of anti-diabetics
it can
so to shift the dial on that biological
clock by about six months now those
clocks are are reasonably good but I
don't think that that's what we should
be aiming for we should be aiming for
the 10 million people who are living
with arthritis the seven and a half
million people with heart disease three
and a half million people living with
chronic kidney disease
um I mean there's about a million people
with living with dementia 25 million
sorry billion pounds a year in the UK
spent on dementia we shouldn't be
thinking about fit healthy people living
another five ten years we should be
looking at the people who are living in
really poor health at the end of their
lives and trying to make that better and
I think that might come on to your point
as well so what I'm very interested in
is something called multimorbidity you
don't just have heart disease or
diabetes or dementia you generally have
all of them and this really massively
impacts on quality of life and it not
just for the individual it's massive for
the individual it's massive for their
families but it's also massive for
society so Frailty alone 5.7 billion
pounds and the reason the NHS is on its
last legs unplanned admissions to
hospital from sick older people if we
preserve People's Health in later life
we preserve their quality of life their
reason for living that of their families
we have a more productive Workforce and
Auntie haldane from Chief treasurer of
the bank of England has estimated that
one extra healthy year of life not
extending overall lifespan but just
reducing the period spent in poor health
by just one year is worth 60 billion
pounds a year to the UK economy when you
look at our um current deficit that
might do what it might fill the Gap a
little bit if we could just keep people
healthier for longer Steve any thoughts
from you before I move on to the next
question the question of what we might
be living longer for is an interesting
one and a few survey people about how
long they want to live then they're
often very split on whether they want to
live much longer but of course we don't
need to all take the same view I mean we
don't need to to think of Life Extension
as a sentence we impose upon people
unwillingly who would be quite happy to
go at 70 but nor do we have to think of
it as a death sentence we impose on
people who do want to live longer if the
technology is available by depriving
them of it so there are things we do
need to come to a consensus about as a
society in terms of paying for this and
access to this but then there might be
options about what we individually want
to do with this technology
fantastic so I saw a couple more heads
ago there's a gentleman the check shirt
here and a lady at the back in the black
coat
against the wall there
I'll take the ladies question first
um hi yeah um so I know you touched
briefly on epigenetics I just wanted to
go quickly back to that because I find
it quite interesting
um so from my understanding what we do
every day can have an impact on sort of
not to get technical like the
methylation of our DNA and I've read
about how sorry
it can impact our DNA and that can in
turn impact say our children and
grandchildren
um
to what extent do you think because I've
read about obviously lifestyle having an
impact on that what we eat what we drink
how we exercise
um and other sort of factors of
Lifestyle
um what part do you think that has to
play in the future of aging and how we
could actually impact
biological aging of our future
Generations yeah great question on the
epigensics of Aging sir yeah
Financial restrictions of the NHS is
this going to be available to general
public or is it people with Deep Pockets
and also how far away are we looking at
seeing these benefits right great okay
can I do that when then the epigenetics
so
um my view is it shouldn't cost the NHS
more it should actually cost the NHS
less at the moment the NHS isn't a
Health Service it's an illness service
it's very reactive to people getting
sick if we could actually prevent people
from getting sick it's an awful lot
cheaper to do preventative medicine than
it is to do reactive treat stuff if you
could stop people getting dementia
you're saving 25 billion a year that's
quite a big sum
and a lot of these interventions have to
happen sort of very early on in disease
all the dementia medicines that are
being tested are in people who have lost
half of their brain cells it's going to
be very very difficult to bring those
back but it should be cheap and
interventions early on at the very early
starts of disease it's just like
vaccination it's a lot cheaper to
vaccinate against covid than to have the
NHS fall on its knees because the wards
are full of covert patients right
prevention is always cheaper prep for
HIV an awful lot cheaper to give pills
than to have someone living life long
with a Life Changing Life limiting
condition prevention is much cheaper so
if we move towards that model of
preventative interventions that can
improve health it will support the NHS
not kill the NHS it'll also mean that
and these drugs a lot of the drugs we're
looking at as I said are off patent
rapamycin metformin statins these things
are cheap enough to not be limited to
developed Nations they could be used in
other countries with less well-developed
Health Systems so they should be
affordable around the world so I'm not
into the make the billionaires live
forever I'm more into improve the health
for everybody I hope that answers your
question the epigenetic thing very very
interesting so these are the genetic
switches there's a really to me worrying
study that if you expose male rats to
the smell of cherry blossom and give
them an electric shock I didn't do this
um
they get scared of the smell of cherry
blossom and these are males and their
grandchildren I.E two generations down
the line are still scared of the smell
of cherry blossom even though they've
never had the electric shock this is
programmed not in the genes but in the
epigenomes so those little switches on
our genes we used to think with wipes
clear every generation now we know
they're not and and so the sins of the
fathers right it goes further back than
that we have to improve Lifestyles and
remove that socioeconomic inequalities
improve diet for everybody if we are
going to improve health for everybody
and it's got to start now because it's
going to filter through multiple
Generations but we can do stuff about it
so we know that a plant-based healthy
diet with lots of exercise can start to
shift that biological clock in the right
direction so it's malleable but also we
have to be very aware that people
inherit a lot of their epigenome as well
as their genome
any thoughts on either of those I've got
time for one more question so I'm just
going to try and squeeze one in but yeah
so I mean on the question of access to
this technology I mean such an important
question I've got all new technologies
big opportunities but also new
challenges new dilemmas and if we really
do have a suite of technologies that
could allow some people to live vastly
longer but was too expensive for
everyone to live longer then that would
indeed be a new dilemma and I think we
know one lesson from history is that
it's very hard to stop Rich powerful
people from getting what they want
so we in the UK might decide that you
know we want everyone to have equal
access to a bit of this technology
rather than a few people to have access
to the full powers of it but we can
imagine you know some Island somewhere
you know like we have tax Havens now as
a kind of Life Extension Haven and all
the billionaires go there to live
forever but it sounds like the you know
plot of a new reality TV show
um
of flights to the sky thank you that's
great
um I've got the right time for one more
question but I'm actually going to be
really rude and take two user at the
back
so uh my question was about uh reversing
aging as you're talking about but
through regeneration so uh We've looked
into animals that have evolved to be
able to regenerate parts of their body
like the zebrafish who can regenerate
their retina and stuff like that so is
it possible in the near future to
regenerate
bigger parts of our bodies and live
longer in that way
spare parts for our aging body and so
you had a question too there's a
microphone coming its way to you
from behind in front no it's there
yeah um we've yeah we've we've touched
on the the lifestyle effect on on Aging
in terms of uh diet and and what you're
drinking in your exercise and all the
rest of it but is there a sort of
vaguely affordable technology
um for say a few hundred pounds that we
should perhaps be looking at the you
know general population should be
looking at as you know potentially going
to help us in terms of
slowing down our aging and yet okay I'm
going to give you literally like 40
seconds to answer both of those sorry
okay sorry well the Regeneration
question yes Altos labs are looking at
switching the epigenome around which is
essentially reprogramming and we know
that there are some companies out there
not just Silicon Valley but a lot of
companies that are looking at making
stem cells that you can put back in so
that people can regenerate tissues from
within so um so you've got liver failure
maybe get a few liver stem cells in
regrow bits of your liver I know that
people are looking at after heart attack
using cardiac stem cells to a sort of
plasters patches that you put on a heart
after a heart attack to regenerate that
damaged tissue so I think it's really
important to have a new of research so
great question thank you and the
simplest one is there anything on the
cusp is it do we have anything yet
that's going to make a significant
inroad into extending a health span well
one word answer to the question you know
what what is what affordable technology
might help us all to live a healthier
and longer it's exercise
that's what we've got right now so
that's the text that you need well I'm
just going to close by saying if you
could pause aging
what age would you pick
how old would you want to be
it's almost impossible I'd want to be
fit and healthy but I'm sort of quite
happy where I am now
um I'm not sure I'd want to be 19 again
and go through all those traumas that
you get through at 19.
um I I don't know I'm fairly comfortable
yeah people get happier as they get
older well right now I'm at the exactly
of a statistically unhappiest age
I feel like a man in my Prime but uh um
but as people get older as a rule they
do get happier early retirees tend to be
very happy so the idea that youth owns
everything I I think is mistaken
fantastic well thank you both very much
for joining us it's been absolutely
fascinating and of course to all of you
for coming along and your brilliant
questions thanks very much indeed
[Applause]